et
c'est frappant de voir seul diminué ça
va être à chaque scène on va vraiment
l'évolution
une étape très nerveux ou dans leurs
ports et des modestement
on comprend que c'est la nature on
pourra pas se battre comme ça
il faut surtout prendre au sérieux la
mesure du défi auquel on est confronté
[Musique]
le défi c'est l'érosion côtière un
phénomène naturel qui sculpte depuis
toujours les contours de l'archipel mais
avec les changements climatiques dame
nature est de plus en plus déjantée
résultat les roseaux s'accélère à la
vitesse grand v
protégez votre vin on a tous vus
remettre des feuilles de contreplaqué
les madelinots comme jean marie martinet
sont aux premières loges des grands
bouleversements liés au changement
climatique sont organisés pour strappé
ça mais c'est martin et doit tous rangés
dans quelques jours son restaurant le
four à pain sera déplacée
donc ça va être ici à partir de
maintenant quand vous perdez votre
stationnement une facture du
stationnement
sans quoi son bâtiment pourrait prendre
le large le restaurateur dit avoir perdu
25 m de terrain principalement dans les
dernières années fait en moyenne 30 ans
n'est plus rien vous
savez pas été dans vos choix
les changements climatiques font que le
niveau de la mer monte submerge
territoire et la couche de glace qui
protège l'archipel durant l'hiver tend à
disparaître
laissant les cons totalement exposée
face à des tempêtes hivernales plus
violente et plus fréquents
d'ici 30 ans les scientifiques estiment
qu'il y aura 60 à 70 jours de moins de
glace chaque hiver
monsieur martinez espère qu'il aura
bientôt l'esprit tranquille bah c'est
notre gagne pain c'est la vie de neuf
personnes dans une demi
d'années avant d'année et en a tellement
vu tellement d'histoires dans l'avenir
du chalet familial d'isabelle cormier
est moins certain lui ça c'était devant
votre petite maison il ya de ça trois
ans mais une tempête de grêle tempête
ouais c'est parti alors que pendant 40 à
elle était là exactement
visité plusieurs
savaient plusieurs de nos vaches à lait
la maison n'a plus aucune protection
naturelle et subit maintenant
régulièrement des inondations
contrairement au restaurant de monsieur
martin est isabelle craint qu'il ne
puisse survivre à un déplacement même si
le chalet familial risquent d'être
éventuellement avalés par la mer emporte
en 40 ans de souvenirs c'est surtout
pour l'environnement qu'isabelle
s'inquiètent j'ai fait un peu mon deuil
c'est un deuil mais pas nécessairement
pour le chalet pour le milieu d'une
acquis qu'il protégeait aux îles de la
madeleine la majorité des gens comme
isabelle ne parle plus de combattre les
changements climatiques mais plutôt de
s'y adapter c'est l'adaptation pc c'est
la résilience
pcc dans l'innovation il ya des gens qui
travaillent là dessus et c'est ce que
tente de faire la municipalité des
îles-de-la-madeleine il faut changer des
règlements adoptés les nouveaux
règlements faire des choix ce recul et
se déplacer peut-être arrêter se
construit en bordure des lacs des
rivières trop près évidemment des points
de vue ici avec le littoral
la municipalité prend tellement le défi
au sérieux qu'elle a embauché une
personne dédiée aux dossiers liés au
changement climatique
félix-antoine langlois qui relève le
défi ici il supervise cette recharge de
plage sur le site historique de la grave
le projet consiste à engraisser la plage
de plusieurs mètres du rouge avec du
gravier
et à s'allonger vers le lange est ce que
ça fait c'est que l'énergie des vagues
quand il va en fait ils vont déferler
plus longtemps sur une plage qui pue
autres il ya quand même un tablier qui
restent ou qui vont empêcher le
franchissement en fait
sur la voie tout sur les maisons
[Musique]
le projet de 6 millions de dollars
financés par la municipalité du
gouvernement du québec après des années
à voir le jour convaincre les
fonctionnaires convaincre le pôle it et
faire des montages financiers faire des
analyses étudie les différentes options
contre eux vérifient les différentes
options tout cela a pris cinq ans c'est
un travail inimaginable c'est un travail
titanesque épuisant je dirai pas ce
qu'il faut se répéter il faut se répéter
faut se répéter et ça ne fait que
commencer les interventions urgentes et
préventif pour protéger l'archipel se
comptent par dizaines le maire prévient
que la communauté de 13 mille résidents
ne peut assumer seule le fardeau
financier et la complexité des défis qui
s'accumulent ici il ya un défi qui est
plus grand que nature il ya un défi qui
est plus grands qui dépassent des
proportions la communauté désigne donc
faut être beaucoup plus proactifs il
faut avoir des enveloppes disponible au
québec qui correspond au phénomène
auquel on est confronté actuellement
le ministère des transports intervient
lorsque la situation est urgente comme
ici avec de l'enrochement pour protéger
la route 199 qui s'est fait gruger par
la main
le maire est stupéfait de constater
l'absence d'investissements pour
l'adaptation et la prévention la part
des gouvernements il n'y a pas d'arrière
pays ici le territoire il est exigu
comparons le pain de l'importance de
protéger de façon durable pour que oui
aujourd'hui on continue d'habiter d'un
territoire mais qu'on puisse léguer une
occupation de territoires nos enfants
qu'est la limite on se permet de rêver
encore plus loin à des enfants à leur
tour au 6 mai pour se forger aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui a manqué dans le passé
maintenant maintenant on a cet âge et en
pro activité d'anticiper ces changements
on voit la vente problèmes qui ont
réparé les les brèches qui rend la dig
vulnérables on
méthode douce
pour faire de la prévention les
madelinots peuvent au moins compter sur
les organismes communautaires comme
attention fragile catherine leblanc jean
et son équipe s'affairent entre autres à
créer une colonisation dame au fil
solitude une plante vivace qui retient
le sable et à l'ensablement mais parfois
aussi il ya la submersion côtières comme
la dig est fragilisée mais ça l'est une
porte d'entrée
énorme pour les vagues de tempêtes avec
les surcote de marée qui le fait bien en
bas et le milieu l'ofas vient perturber
l'équilibré cosmique
ici ils installent des cages à homard
qui viennent ralentir le vent chargé de
sable des cages fournis par des pêcheurs
du secteur on a discuté avec eux ce sont
les aveux on les a impliqué dans le
processus ils se sont sentis
interpellé une implication essentiel
selon m je pense que on est tous
responsables de la protection de notre
environnement le ont fait partie de
l'écosystème
catherine crois que l'inaction n'est pas
une option j'ai envie de voir grandir
mes enfants ici puis qu'ils exactement
les mêmes paysages
je peux qu'y êtres aux problèmes
environnementaux à agir et et j'aimerais
ce que la vie a soit cinq pour résoudre